what's going on this is division you can
check us out right now on the blue light
kev podcast
bootleg cab show special guest in the
building we have division ladies and
gentlemen what up what up what's up what
up
well first of all i want to say uh
on behalf of uh
men all over the place that aren't to me
because i i can't relate to this
particular record why are you speaking
on their behalf
because i have friends who relate uh
strongly to
this record is very very
appreciated
by the male demographic in the world
is this something that you guys i mean
obviously personal experience you went
through and you're like yo this how come
we don't have one of these
yeah i mean i mean tell us how much of a
piece of [ __ ] you are
honestly the record is not
it's not what you guys are taking it as
first and foremost well i mean the hook
is very uh factual though the everything
in a record is factual i'm saying like
if i you know if i don't just because i
get caught yeah i mean i don't love you
right because when you break it down
cheating is it's not about that for a
lot of people when they're cheating it's
men specifically a lot of men
specifically relate to it right correct
um but we've heard from women too and
there's a lot of girls that are like yo
i
i kind of just wanted to go out there
and
[ __ ] or i got you know i got caught up
in this situation or i felt low about
myself
i wanted to feel sexy again and this
person over here made me feel that way
you know i didn't stop loving my person
the moment the moment i was finished i
felt like [ __ ] what did i just do
you know that that feeling so i've i've
been on
i think we've both been on probably both
sides of that that fence both you guys
have cheated and been cheated on
i think i've been cheated on i'm not i
don't have the you don't know for sure
well then you don't know
yeah i don't know but it looks
it it looks it looks suspect yes i had a
god-awful terrible dumpster fire of a
human being as a baby mother so wow
shout out to her dumpster fire she's a
[ __ ] terrible person she's somewhere
probably
doing heroin right now i don't know [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
i have my son this only matters um
anyway uh so yeah so like
was this your idea okay so let me break
it down
we have been working on this album with
germain dupree real closely darn be god
salute what up jd um we walked into the
studio
um
and he's
literally opens the door singing that
chorus
opens doors to the face
i don't mean i don't love you and i was
like
what and i was like oh my god that's
exactly what i want to say in life and i
was like i've never heard somebody just
say it was so it's it's put so simply
but it's a it's a deep thought 100 right
and so
i we walk in
brian michael cox is already messing
around with jesus he's just legendary
yeah yeah already just you know he's
going at it
um
19 has the idea to be like yo
what if we flip some of our old ideas
where we used to put like girl choirs on
stuff
and
make it men a whole bunch of guys this
time so that way it can you know help
express that this isn't this is a
thought that seemed that feels universal
right a lot of people can relate to this
so i thought that was genius and i sat
down and i wrote this these verses now
these verses have been highly taken out
of
uh
perspective i think okay
on people's first maybe second would you
say there's a little misunderstanding
about the meaning yes okay yeah so
i'm writing about
a guy that's
in a relationship where the his partner
starts to feel like maybe they're
cheating on them
and i'm writing this from the
perspective of someone who's like yo
everything you everything that attracted
you to me
has now turned into your insecurities
right that happens a lot happens a lot
guys and girls yeah right
so it's like you you liked me for
for who i was for being fly for being a
good looking dude for being you know
funny cool whatever all these things but
now because as soon as i leave the crib
it's an issue yeah you want me to yeah
you dressed up exactly exactly like you
got a brand new shirt on where are you
going where are you going you know oh
you're going over there oh you're going
to oh you're going to be talking and all
these
these hoes faces you got to be the life
of the party like it's like you met me
this way you liked me because of these
things you always liked being around my
energy all these things like that and
now it's turned into this now you're
digging through phones and you know
checking instagram followers and you all
that stuff like that so that's the
perspective that i'm writing about it so
people hear me say i'm a fly [ __ ] when
you got here charismatic when you got
here and they're thinking oh he's
telling the girls like he was fly you
should already know i'm gonna be [ __ ]
these hoes or something but it's like
that's not what i was saying i was
saying i was these things and now well
that's also a very important thing to
convey because a lot of people feel that
way what that i was flying i was already
[ __ ] these hoes no that oh
when you get into a relationship like
you said it always happens whether it's
the guy or the girl
when you think about it a lot of dudes
will meet a chick in the club who's
[ __ ] beautiful [ __ ] ass out
whatever and it's like well that's how
you met this girl that's what attracted
you to her exactly now that you cuffed
her like you can't get mad she's going
out with her homegirls exactly so that's
that's the perspective i wrote the
verses from and then i was like it gets
into the the idea of
okay so now you're now you're doing the
dig into the phone [ __ ]
are you trying to find a problem or are
you trying to find an actual reason to
leave
and then comes the
because and why would why would you want
to leave when even if hypothetically i
was to cheat on you it wouldn't be
because all of a sudden i just lost my
feelings for you and i i don't love you
anymore right it would be probably
because i just did something super
selfish super self-indulgent
super you know me being addicted to my
[ __ ] short-sighted you know stroking
my ego all these other things and i
think that's the mis a big misconception
with people about why people cheat and
that's why we wanted to bring it to the
table it's usually not
about the other person especially with
guys sometimes sometimes you hear women
say you know that you know they only did
it because
there was a lack of something or a void
or emotional disconnect whatever it is
they were getting something in their
relationship they went to go find it but
guys
especially a lot of guys i know
girls too but a lot of guys commonly we
can hear that yo
they have the girl they want right this
is just literally had nothing to do with
them i mean if you think about like uh
all of the
like halle berry's been cheated on you
know i'm saying like and girls say that
he goes like how do you cheat on this
person and every guy gets it honestly i
think we're guys we think beyonce got
cheated on me i think what guys the more
you have that you actually wanted the
less you feel inclined to stay because
we're used to chasing
so we're used to looking for the other
things so you if you actually have
everything at home i feel like there's a
twisted thing that happens in guys where
they start being like something's
missing like i miss the chase i'm not
doing what my what i feel like my nature
just pushes me things
it's not something that we can't control
it's something that we can't just say no
to but
it's something that a lot of people fall
into right and i don't think that when
they do
it's talked about enough that
a lot of times it's not because
they just don't love you anymore it's
because of some other issues that they
probably
got to work out maybe they maybe they
need to feel more desired maybe their
self-esteem is a little low and this is
how they boost it maybe this is an ego
thing maybe this maybe they haven't
i don't know whatever it is just you
know addiction to the chase like you're
saying so and women at times have an
addiction to chasing down your phone and
trying to just find something to fight
about even if you're not cheating right
and and so
that is really
i like that i like when you know
you use what's going on here to shoot
out there yeah but
nah um
i really feel like i really feel like
that's the conversation that we wanted
to
put on the table and and know that we
wanted people to let's talk about it
yeah because no one no one wants to talk
about it everyone wants to act
so like it's so taboo and i think that
that's what made the record really go
and it's making the record really go is
the fact that
it's so real and it's like hella
under served
niche like in r b
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like we don't have like an anthem like
that there's never been any men enjoy r
b i love r b and you know i feel like
there's so much scorned woman music yeah
there's not many songs that i feel like
speak to
this demographic that's embraced it so
well just like every man in the world
except me obviously
yeah there you go 100 yeah yeah so the
germain debris thing obviously jd one of
the greatest producers of all time but
specifically when it comes to the r b
[ __ ] he's
i mean i don't know man he might be the
goat you know i mean you think of
confessions and i mean [ __ ] jd's
that [ __ ]
what was the initial like uh
link up with jd and like having him
handle a lot of the reigns on the
project it wasn't supposed to be that on
on first meet up we were really just
meeting my our um
management team just set up
you know me going through to go say what
up to them right meet jermaine dupri
and you know fast forward
two three days and it's like
you know
we're together every day right you know
we talk every day you know the
relationships turn from
hero to you know big bro [ __ ] yeah you
know like i don't think there's a day
that goes by we're not calling or
texting about whatever it is you know at
this point what is something that you
guys learn creatively
from jd because you know when you're
like that prolific i feel like i'm sure
a lot of the stuff he does just seems
like effortlessly but at the end of the
day you could probably grab from
oh being around that i think it is that
though everything he does seems so
effortless
that when we're with him he's always
telling us we're thinking too hard
you'll be the first to be like bro
you're thinking about this way too hard
like if you haven't got it by now either
move on or it's that thing right there
you know so that's his like
hit formula he can tell you in like 10
seconds yeah that's gonna go now that's
not the one
it's the craziest thing with him and and
it it really shows in this record
because
what i like to say that i think he's
great at is
is real genius and what i mean by that
is
there's a level of genius that i think
that is
for
intel intellectual people to catch
but i think there's another higher tier
where even if you're not smart you still
recognize the genius
right and he's a way that like finds a
way of making everything genius so
simple well that like a kid can get it
right yeah and that's what i'm saying
he's just like he's just great his
record's supposed to be palatable to
everybody they should be right yeah
exactly so and i think that we've always
i think that's something that we really
um
could have always used some of that
because i think sometimes we've made
like almost higher intellectual
r b even in there it's just like we
gotta we gotta think oh we really listen
to intelligent sometimes the music from
from our perspective and i think he was
very
clear with us about like yo whatever you
guys have been doing is beautiful music
but let's make things that kind of go
across the board like people need to
understand it on the most basic level
they don't need to be able to they don't
have to like break it down to be like
well this this and this happened that's
why that's tied into this line over here
you know it's sometimes if someone just
can just stop you and just be like yo
exactly what you said there just leave
it like that he's great at that and not
overthinking it exactly
and he's like yo for the spot in rmb
that you
want to go take and then i can see that
you
you have what it takes to go take that
this is the way to go it's like no
different than like you know like i
don't know kendrick lamar and like
section 80 which was [ __ ] one of my
favorite kendrick projects right but
then on goodkidmad city he like put some
like hit he put some thought into like
you know some hits i guess
oh my god he took away further for sure
so it's like
a pimp a butterfly he said [ __ ] it i'm
doing me
damn that's true he got to it you know
that's true by the way that's my timing
butterfly is my favorite kendrick album
for the record is it yes
but uh yeah how do you guys like the new
kendrick album
i think it's
such a like beautiful piece of art that
i i only feel like i can play it in
specific moments like i don't feel like
i can play it at all times i have to
like be ready to just like you know i i
felt like that for about a week and now
it's like now you run it just rich
spirit i just like throw that [ __ ] on
and work it out
there's some [ __ ] on there there's some
[ __ ] i feel like when it first came out
i was kind of like
damn what do i like bang though you know
but now
i'm like going back i listen to that
[ __ ] a lot honestly that shouldn't work
out that's what i was if i could if i
could work out to your [ __ ] i feel like
i could hear it on like on the radio or
like hear it in the car you know what
i'm saying but i feel like you gotta say
i feel like more than most albums in the
last four or five years you gotta really
like you're gonna sit with it and you
get i feel like it gets better every
time you listen to it i'm sure it should
as art should yeah i mean um
so
you guys also did a was it last year you
did the ty dolla sign project yeah last
year we did a mixtape with ty um shout
out to tai shout out to one of the
greats um
you guys have two albums out correct we
had
we just dropped our third right before
that
before the thai [ __ ] before the time
okay that's a high mix tape yeah um yeah
yeah i always feel like with the ovo
thing right it's like do you ever feel
like there's like a gift and a curse of
being with ovo because at the end of the
day drake is the biggest artist in the
world he's one of the most talented
artists in the world
um
and
i feel like
i appreciate his ear for who he signs to
the label because there's always like
high
i mean i wouldn't say always
but for the most part high artistic
integrity when i think of like majid
jordan and you guys um
i feel like he also
is allowing people to develop like
artist development's like a real thing
of ovo if that makes sense but at the
same time that takes time and when
you're signed to drake people probably
expect you to just come out swinging
with like you know [ __ ] hit records
and drake features and all this [ __ ]
trick is
people look at
his
what he does for features and what he
does for the the label
as two separate things and they expect
the same things i think it's different i
think him jumping on a record versus him
signing you
his mental approach to that is just
completely different i think like he
might find a record and be like cool i'm
gonna just hop on this wave come on come
on there drop this
yeah drop this elevate this record and
they call it the drake stimmy pack yeah
the stimmy right yes whereas i think
with artists that that he's involved
with you know the business of signing i
think that he likes to
be like
this person's dope give them give them
what they need
this person's dope you know gives them
what they need
versus the approach that he takes when
he's just like i'm jumping on a rock
right i just feel like it's like dope
because i you'll see like artist
development happening at ovo like you
know what i'm saying like it's not
always like the the cheat code is like
let me just get on a song
knowing what that's going to do that's
also the easiest way for people to fail
i mean because if you take an artist
that's not in
the drake position right
you give them the drake
and then
and
then insert name here
who's no longer relevant exactly you
know and that's why we've always been
really appreciative of the way that he's
embraced things and let us kind of
develop on our own
path right figure that out at the same
time like
we still can go back and forth with
records or ideas and that's how we ended
up on the views album or that's how he's
had songs that he's written and he'll
throw it to us and be like yo what do
you think of this record you want to do
something with it or you know and
there's always been that freedom but
there's never the pressure to feel like
you guys don't have to do
the drake way of doing things so you
don't have to do it the way
the traditional like label process would
be not only that but i think it helps
every artist on the label kind of
own
own their brand
right that's smart yeah because i think
that division like we have our we
definitely have our own brand and your
own cult following following our fans
that's independent of everything
independent of anything yeah so i i love
that we've been able to
to to to have the space to do that and
to be you know successful in doing that
what was his reaction when you heard
this record we haven't we haven't talked
to anybody since we dropped
jesus
bro we literally
in the tunnels just trying to get this
album done so justice over there doesn't
kill us um
but we literally haven't talked to
anybody sent no we don't we literally
locked in the studio
cooked up and popped our head out to
drop this and even this record why we
popped our head up to drop this is
because we've been inviting people to
hear to the studio just to you know hear
things yeah and
every time we played that record the
whole room would burst into argument
for like half an hour an hour time so
we're like yo what is happening and
every guy felt like liberated some women
are like yeah you know what i get that
you know it's honest some girl's like oh
it's a bop some girls are like i'm i'm
triggered you know i'm mad no it's a
trigger you know there's the and we're
just like yo what is happening this has
never happened with a song like this so
because of that we just
we got to get this thing out
this is also the first album that we've
done outside of toronto
you guys where you guys are in atlanta
yeah everything's been in jail
yeah
it's amazing whose idea was it was your
idea of jd's idea to sample jay
the jay-z both of us because me and jd
were joking about how
ridiculous that
line is
it's like yo that's a crazy line what if
we use it and then i was like i don't
really think i can do that he's like why
i don't think we're gonna get that clear
he's like i'll handle the clearance
stuff you just sample however you see
like how you see that fitting in the
record and i'll do the rest and he he
did he took care of it oh cleared it oh
cleared it i mean and it's it's it's
cool because i bring i saw i actually
saw the like uh
i think the chex conversation or
whatever that that came out about
hopefully and i didn't hear the record
yet
so when i heard it i was like oh [ __ ]
they they use that
and it's perfect for the uh for the
songs yeah it works it was that's messed
up
because again to say something like that
you know again you're you're in your
full ego at that moment to be able to
tell somebody like
it was just [ __ ] yeah i was just i
was just doing that like i was coming
right back and thinking that that's
okay what percentage are we done with
the album or is it done or is it close
97 to 98. you guys get ursher on the
album
i mean you're gonna have to wait and see
i don't know oh sure on the remix at
least yo i said you're gonna have to
wait and see
[Music]
it feels like a yeah
yeah you said yeah because of the usher
that feels like there's a nice
connection there
yeah yeah
what about the brat i'm just kidding
that would be random as [ __ ] you just
have like the
no she's just like oh this record is so
fire
uh
yeah so first album outside of toronto
right or just canada in general what
part are you guys both from toronto
you're from toronto
i keep hearing about toronto it's
amazing man you gotta come i heard it's
like
yeah i heard it's a vibe
yeah everybody i know from you guys are
just the nicest people
canadians are just so sweet man i don't
know one [ __ ] is a canadian now you
guys probably do because you're from
there
all the canadians that come into contact
seem to be sweet guys
yeah what is it why is that
i don't think that's accurate
so well
why is it the i i just feel like is it
because there's like [ __ ] you know uh
free health care less distress about i
think we're just less aggressive people
in general yeah i think that you guys
call ham canadian bacon
no there's ham no canadian bacon is a
certain type that's the way it's got not
not a papa john's you get that papa
john's you say ham we got canadian bacon
and it comes in its hand i know a lot of
people i got to say this because toronto
people will see this i know a lot of
toronto people
that feel the complete opposite
about toronto versus states
i'm actually like everyone from the u.s
is nice super nice really have you ever
been to like i don't know [ __ ]
tennessee or mississippi or something no
so that's what i'm saying maybe i
haven't been you've been to like places
cali atlanta atlanta houston
i'll go to the middle of america yeah
yeah i'm saying that's different so but
i'm saying the places that i go
the
the
people that i meet as far as especially
in comparison to the black community in
toronto it's way more love
especially in the south and stuff like
that amongst them
versus than it is in toronto and i think
it's the
southern
hospitality it's it i think it's also
the the the
to get all deep but i think no really i
know not to get all deep jesus but i
think it's that i think it's the fact
that i think it's the fact that um
people have always there's always been
like and the just the racism
idea of it all um has kind of made black
people kind of feel to other black
people like oh you're one of us right
right you know and in toronto it's a lot
of the island culture like jamaican and
island culture kind of runs that and
island people are just
you know they have their own attitude
about them at all times they kind of
that's kind of what they are like
i have no comment
when you get there you can you'll
yeah i won't even make a comment then
everybody's nice
yeah the world's nice
how do you feel about uh you guys have
justin trudeau running your country and
i know that like there's like a crazy
like
i know people [ __ ] with them and then
covet happened and it seems like he's i
don't how do y'all feel about this guy
i i think covert made everything
different
you know i won't say
better or worse i think it made things
different and
this was one of the few times that
the world looked at canada as not being
like one of the leaders
as far as
the way things were handled right you
know i think people always look to
canadians like oh the way they do it up
there is they got you know they got off
yeah they get the health care stuff
together yeah this is one of the first
times where it seemed like we weren't
necessarily the front runner
as far as how certain things were
handled even right now the airports are
crazy and you know
there shouldn't be that much of a
difference between
uh even us in the states as far as
how we've um
kind of transitioned out of total i
don't know if we have transitioned out i
think we're coming right back into it i
mean you guys have been in atlanta you
guys know it don't exist there
what
no how many how many meals you guys
shared at a strip club in the last 12
months in atlanta
at least one right
yeah at least
yeah blue flame got great wings that's
one of the strip clubs i actually still
haven't gone to yet there's like a
there's a strip club there that plays
terrible music uh it's like nickel back
and like
crazy i know exactly what you're talking
about lamb chops i know exactly what
you're talking about it's actually right
up the side right from south side it's
like yeah they got great lamb chops
no he's not talking about cheetah he's
not talking about cheetah i think he's
right no they got the lamb chop cheetah
is definitely playing nickelback it's
the uh i swear it's the other one up
this up the street from jimmy no no no
like three times in the last when i went
there they were playing some [ __ ]
nickel bags
when i went to cheetah they were by the
way
nickelback canadian yeah when's that
happening boys when we gonna do the
little [ __ ] collab huh are they still
out
man
that's a big song is that your [ __ ]
they got that call they go back
people ate that nickelback but i was
like i think i kind of secretly have a
couple bangers
they got a few spiderman soundtracks the
spiderman soundtrack i liked hero hero
track i liked
yeah their music is uh
better than creeds i'll tell you that
is it i thought that i thought people i
thought oh no creed's music was
atrocious oh wow people people always
[ __ ] on nickelback like they're the
they're the
[Music]
lesser crete is what i always people
thought but i'm trying to figure out a
word that's not going to be cancelled
that they're the somethingist band in
the world right but they're not but
readers no wait what's the something
well come on just give us what's the
word man something is you know no i
don't they're the
world
wow
we're just gonna bleep that out
[Laughter]
it's almost like it's like it's like
nickelback is like the
[Music]
but all these bands aren't they just
kind of like the flow rider of like
rocks
right
right
with the poppy it's poppy right yeah
okay
like lincoln park was poppy you know
like
i guess but not but i like lincoln park
yeah
creed's from canada or not creed uh you
know nickel back from canada so those
y'all you know y'all gotta [ __ ] stick
together man yeah that'd be kind of
crazy if y'all did a record with creed
it might sound terrible wait creed's
canadian you mean nickelback i keep
saying creed nickelback right i'm
confusing my caucasians
i'm confusing my shitty rock bands guys
jesus
here we are uh so do we have any idea
when the project will be dropping in the
next couple of months
so soon yeah nice how fun was the uh the
little photo shoot shot that was the
with the you know you were for the
singles oh
that wasn't we had to do that a couple
times just to make it look
that way but um no it's dope the the the
models all
all um
got into character nice
how'd you get into character for it i
put on a silk shirt
you wear those like normally yeah
uncomfortable no silk uncomfortable like
if it's hot i'm from arizona so it
doesn't like stick together no just it's
the breathiest floatiest yeah i don't
know i've never worn it
when you're shaped like me i'm shaped
like a bag of potatoes i can't wear a
[ __ ] silk shirt you said you're in
the gym now you're listening to me i am
i've been working out i have been
working out
but i still i still i still still got
the dad bod
what do i look like in a silk shirt bro
like seriously look at miami he's gonna
get a boat
get a [ __ ] pair of shorts some fresh
white air force shorts
you see that all the time come on man
[Music]
everyone says i look like scott
scorcher's little brother this is the
thing did you say that on purpose
no don't do that to me bro scott's a
great guy jeff storch
have you met scott storch
one time great guy chain smoker
great guy great guy very talented
he's like i would say he's where would
you guys put him all the time top 15 who
disgust
as a producer yeah
top 15. rap you sing rap or are you
saying i'm saying rap yeah because if
you go all raw i'm saying what
because of how high dre is going to be
and people don't realize how much much
so
especially 2001 yeah
then i think you got to put him not i
think he could get top 15. yeah
not far i don't know i think people just
forget how much he did yeah who's your
who's your like top five producers
hip-hop
all-time
wow
top five
yay
timberland
neptune's
primo
just there's too many just blaze
just places um
so you don't have a drain there and you
don't have germain to pre-i give [ __ ]
him right he's just doing your whole
album not as there's too many yeah
because jermaine
is like so much bigger than just hip-hop
i agree i agree so it's timberland but i
actually feel like i actually feel like
timbaland if you think about the range
i don't know if anyone's [ __ ] with
timberland now my personal favorite ever
is just blaze like he's my personal
favorite i know he's not the best but
he's my personal number one but
timbaland to me is like the range if you
think about the justin timberlake
his range is the least [ __ ] tim was my
favorite was my favorite producer i
actually just met him for the first time
maybe like
three weeks ago with jermaine there was
like a bubba sparks album called
deliverance those beats are wild that is
crazy so crazy
no one talks about that album i'm like
y'all understand this [ __ ] did a
whole country rap album that was like
flawless
haven't heard that album deliverance is
crazy don't listen to the first album is
like the one with ugly which is a great
record but the second one is the one
we're sampling all kinds of like folk
country and [ __ ] yeah yeah timbaland's
that guy man let's check it out so we're
getting an album in the next couple
months
uh videos dope
uh i saw that uh joe budden was a little
critical of this record he's a fan of
you guys obviously but uh was that just
coming with having maul in the video i
mean i think
definitely maul played a part in that i
think we knew once maul was in the video
i mean it's crazy because um
i i wasn't thinking about it at all and
then i it hit me i was like oh you know
what joe mike jill's going to probably
have something to say because he said
you guys talk right you enjoy we you
know we dm and
then he's an rmb fan like he talks about
r b a lot yeah he he you know he's he's
good for
saying a lot of
real things but he's also good for just
kind of just saying things sometimes so
it is what it is you know he's
he i think he said we dropped an album
in 2016 then another one in 2019
and so we don't drop enough for him and
i was like that is not our album
that's not accurate at all but shout out
to joe you know whatever it is what it
is you just can't he's just not the
division wikipedia he thinks he is yeah
and sometimes he's just wrong on records
wrong great right this one's already
proven that he's went out and you know
he said what he said and you know i
think the same
maybe like a few days later we heard the
most number one added song to urban
radio you know so
you're wrong
i think it's like i think i watched that
clip
um and i think
i think he's probably like
it's kind of like uh if you're like a
really big fan of like an underground
rapper right
and then they put out like
a song with drake or some crazy and
you're just like
you didn't have to you know what i mean
i feel like that that was more his
perspective i don't agree because i love
this [ __ ] song i think the song is
great but i think that like
i feel like you know everybody who
most fans who are with you from the
beginning when you have that first real
big splash
they're kind of like
you know what i mean so maybe he was
just speaking from that perspective
maybe you know i and one thing about
this song that i have noticed whether
it's
you know a critic or just like a
a casual listener or a fan even is
it's it sticks with you in a way that's
different so i think that
even if on first listen you don't want
to like it right on second listen you
realize that you kind of do what you
might not want to say even if you don't
like it it's going to be in your [ __ ]
head you can't get
so it's just it's just that kind of song
which is cool would you guys do a remix
to this record
if the if the right
idea came to mind for sure why not yeah
i feel like when the record gets this
big it's like
people are going to remix it themselves
yeah we've already
you'd almost rather
yeah have like control the reason
control of one um yeah we've seen some
girls start to make their clap backs
which i think is crazy i think it's
amazing i haven't seen any of these any
good ones it's amazing
shout out
baby tate who's uh label mate yeah oh is
she a little she's not okay there you go
so um no she hers was hers was fire um
but you know a bag of girls have started
to to do it and there's a bag of girls a
group like a rap group no no no a bunch
of women oh i see okay
interesting name for a group in 2020 i
know a bunch a bunch of girls have done
it and what i think is very interesting
and i think we knew was going to happen
too besides
this song bring this conversation about
relationship and setting up the story of
the album blah blah blah
it's going to show some some sides of
people it's showing a lot of double
standards in men
it's showing a lot of even hypocrisy
though sometimes with women because
these women are now making super over
the top toxic
clapbacks right and girls are now
cheering it on like yes [ __ ] talk that
[ __ ] you know
they're happy about it
now they have so many of those i love
this women have so many of those so many
what do you mean we get so many insert
armbies insert kishiko's discography
here
everything we've been i have enough
summer walker jesus walker
we got one we haven't had i feel like we
haven't had some [ __ ] like this since
we've seen confessions yeah it's been a
while yeah
have you guys uh was confessions toxic
it wasn't toxic but it was definitely
like oh wow he's like rapping about like
cheating and like [ __ ] up a
relationship and like so why don't
people take this the same way
i think it's a little more blatant and
we're in flames
it's an anthem
like you said you guys did the like mail
like like everyone's chanting
and let's be honest it's 2022.
[ __ ] are [ __ ] out here
i like that wow nobody's used to men
talking like that [ __ ] on records
especially r b they're like oh my god
ruffle for feathers yeah
you guys might [ __ ] when i got
canceled in a few like group chats you
know what i'm saying you don't know for
sure yeah
no but yeah i i it worked because the
shock is you know it's starting to wear
off and people are like
but i like the song well there it is